[موسيقى]
اذا هو اليوم الرابع من كاس العالم 2022
هناك في قطر واليوم من سيلعب المنتخب
المغربي اسود الاطلس اليوم
امام المنتخب الكرواتي المنتخب
اللاعبين الكبار مثل بيرزيت السوبر وغيرهم
من اللاعبين المميزين المنتخب المغربي
اليوم سيدخل مباراه شخصيه يجب ان يدخل
بشخصيه المرشح خليني اسالك سؤال اذا عندك
فريق في لاعبين منتخب في لاعبين بيلعبوا
بايرن ميونخ في لاعبين باريس سان جيرمان
وفي لاعبين اخرين اشبيليه وفريق اخر هو
لاعب وحيد الذي يلعب في ريال مدريد والاخر
يلعب في توتنهام من سيكون المرشح للفوز هل
هو منتخب كرواتيا ولا المنتخب المغربي
المنتخب المغربي لديه لاعبين مميزين جدا
على مستوى عالي من الاحتكاك على مستوى
عالي من الدوريات التي يلعبون بها يلعبون
الدوريات الخمس الكبرى بالمقابل المنتخب
الكرواتي لم يعد ذلك المنتخب لم يعد ذلك
الفريق الذي كان عليه ب 2018
في منتخب كرواتيا في اعتماد كرواتيا
الوحيد سيكون على مودريتش هجوميه وبعض
اللاعبين الصغار ولكن بكل امانه لا يوجد
لاعبين يخشاهم المنتخب المغربي اليوم
اهميه الفوز بالنسبه لمنتخب المغرب الكبير
جدا اليوم الى المغرب حقق الفوز او طلع
بنتيجه ايجابيه راح تسهل عليه مهمه التاهل
دور المقبل حتى لو لاحقا خسر من بلجيكا او
تعثر امام احد الفرق الاخرى في المجموعه
كان كندا او بلجيكا ولكن اموره راح تكون
سليمه ومنتخب المغرب راح يكون قادر يعبر
للدور الثاني لذلك اهميه الانطلاقه دائما
في كؤوس العالم كبيره جدا جدا جدا اعتقد
ان المنتخب السعودي امبارح اعطى دا في
منتخب التونسي يتعادل مع الدنمارك وسيعطي
اليوم دافع لل- للمنتخب المغربي ليفوز على
كرواتيا اليوم مفاتيح لاعب المنتخب
المغربي تتكون بجهتين او بلاعبين اساسيين
نصير مزراوي واشرف حكيمي هذان اللاعبان
المميزان جدا اللي اثبتوا انه هن من اهم
الاظهره في العالم مش في افريقيا ولا
الدول العربيه لا لا لا في العالم فا نحن
اليوم عم نحكي عن فرصه ذهبيه وتاريخيه
للمنتخب المغربي ليحقق شيء في كؤوس العالم
شئ يتجاوز به انجاز الثمانينات ويصل الى
مراحل متقدمه اكثر من ذلك لا يجب ان يخشى
المنتخب الكرواتي لانه مثل ما قلنا المغرب
اليوم كعب عالي على كرواتيا بالتوفيق
للمنتخب المغربي وبالتوفيق ايضا للمشجعين
المنتخب كرواتيا والمنتخب الكرواتي في هذه
الموقع المحتدمه جدا هنا في قلب العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه